so um all right thank you and um
it's a big pleasure to be here uh it's
great to have followed such a wonderful
talks and i particularly um
mercedes has already highlighted for
malaria the importance of understanding
social and local vulnerabilities as well
as uh climate and then jeff has already
emphasized the importance of water and
then max on temperature so i have a sort
of great platform if you like for the
talk that i want to give you but my talk
is a little bit different
in
its focus and that is that we talk a lot
about
what climate is doing but what are we
going to do
about it that's the basic essence and
what are people doing about it now i
come from the international research
institute for climate and society which
is based at columbia and um
uh uh it's a mission-driven institute
and our mission is not only just to
understand and anticipate which we've
learned a lot about this morning but
also to help society manage aspects of
climate variability and change and it's
the management side that i'm going to
emphasize in my talk with where i hope i
can add
some value to the previous speakers and
there are many colleagues of mine at the
iri and elsewhere that um are involved
in these studies and contribute uh to my
thinking in general
i did want to mention that i woke up
this morning at five o'clock from a
nightmare and it was i don't normally
have nightmares i don't remember my
dreams that much but it was a big night
it was like a real shock and i had
dreamt that i was going on stage to sing
at the opera and i knew i couldn't sing
and not only that they hadn't told me
what the tune was and there was this
anyway so i am very glad that it's not
my name and i'm sure you're very glad
that i'm not going to sing opera instead
i'm going to tell you something about
how we can think about the way climate
and environment is changing and how we
might be anticipating changes and what
we can actually use that information for
that's the essence of my talk so my
focus is on malaria and we've heard
some things about the changes in malaria
transmission over time and the history
of disease etc this is a useful map in
terms of its uh the spatial distribution
of malaria over the last century and i
particularly want you to focus on
changes uh post um
that happened after the second world war
and these changes were really driven by
the eradication campaigns and
i'll give you a little bit of
information around that but over time
you can see the reduction if you like
from this global disease to a disease of
the tropics and a disease which is
particularly
stubborn in terms of getting rid of it
in africa
and if we go and look at the phases of
malaria control and the sort of policy
environment that's happened since the
second world war and there was this
control phase that came in with the
league of nations the development of the
global uh control uh and strategies
followed by an eradication phase
a resurgence of disease
chaos in the 1980s and from the 1990s
hope and these all relate to policy
changes that happened at the global
scale these policy changes are
incredibly significant in terms of
what you're talking about whether or not
it's going to actually influence
anything in terms of disease
transmission and morbidity and mortality
for people who are currently uh
suffering and dying from malaria there's
still you know over a million deaths a
year from malaria uh estimated yeah so
um
a particular importance if you like in
terms of the hope are those uh policy
changes that happened in the 1990s which
was the adoption of a new control
strategy by ministers of health uh
globally and how that changed into a
global malaria strategy uh for the world
and particularly the launch of rollback
malaria in 1998 but we're really going
to pick up the story with
in 2000 with the development of the
millennium development goals now one
thing i wanted to ask is could i have a
quick show of hands
roughly do you identify yourself more on
the climate side or on the health side
so if that just give me a sense of the
audience so climate
health
ah interesting okay well the health
people will know would be much more
familiar with this but maybe some of the
climate people will not uh be quite so
familiar
so the millennium development goals
which are these eight major goals uh
around the eradication of poverty and
universal education equality of women
and reductions in child mortality
improvement in maternal health combating
hiv and malaria of the diseases
environmental sustainability and global
partnerships for development these are
the big things that the un agencies and
the global
decision-making community signed up for
in 2000 and malaria was central to most
of them
because malaria has a huge impact on
child mortality and on maternal
mortality it's a direct one under number
six where it's named explicitly but it
also affects
education it affects
poverty eradication etc so malaria over
the last 10 years has gained the global
stage
and gained huge amounts of resources
relative to the virtual zero resources
or very low resources uh that were
available to malaria control post the
eradication phase so from 1970s 1980s
and early 1990s there was very little
resources going into malaria
so when you see what's happening on the
malaria policy side and then you bring
in what's happening on the climate uh
change side this was the original phd
we've seen this graph before from pin
martins where the first if you like
attempts to relate climate change and uh
to malaria transmission and if you like
the focus of the climate change
community had been and rightly so in one
way to grab the attention of policy
makers to sort of somehow make climate
change real
and uh to do it by saying look it's
actually going to impact uh the places
uh that you're concerned about europe
and the us
this may have backfired in one way or
another um because part of it is that
the global health community did not buy
onto climate change for at least another
10 years
and uh market change who's the director
she gave the first speech of any
director on climate change
at bethesda
in december 2007. 10 years after those
initial studies and a long time after i
feel like there'd been a lot of
discussion in the literature on climate
change and
health
and one of the reasons maybe these
people here
and
uh the gates foundation have rege
energized in many ways malaria control
through their resourcing of malaria
research and control commodities and
development etc and in particular they
have refocused the global health
community on eradication again so in the
1950s there was a global strategy for
eradication of malaria with ddt and
chloroquine which got rid of malaria out
of the u.s got rid of it out of
large parts of europe and large parts of
asia and then malaria researched in many
of the not in the u.s in europe but in
in parts of asia
but now we have a return of the idea
that you can eradicate malaria anybody
who knows about malaria is an incredibly
complicated disease and when bill gates
announced this in 2007 there was sort of
shock and horror in the audience
from many uh malariologists who thought
this is really not possible and not a
sensible policy objective however he has
been very effective at ruining the
health community and
that is now elimination is now part of
the global strategy for many countries
and if you look at the difference just
for some quick definitions uh
you have control which is basically
going every year trying to just make a
reduce the impact of malaria elimination
trying to get malaria down to zero
incidents
in specific regions of the world and
then eradication really getting a
permanent reduction uh to zero in the
worldwide incidence of infection this is
like smallpox eradication yeah and then
extinction is really when there's no
parasite left on the planet and so i
don't think people are quite considering
that but it's moved the whole policy
agenda again away from control through
elimination towards eradication so you
have if you like in two different
agendas going on a climate change agenda
predicting malaria into the future and
the malaria gender predicting the end of
malaria
so what are we going to do in this
discussion yeah so one of the things
that we've been doing at the iri is
thinking very much of climate as an
opportunity as a way to help public
health decision making improve their
decisions to get to that objective of
eradicating malaria faster and the way
we're interested in doing this is using
climate information to help but better
understand the mechanisms of disease to
better estimate populations at risk to
improve our understanding of seasonality
and the timing of interventions to
monitor and predict year-to-year
variations in incidents
including early warning systems to
monitor and predict longer-term trends
but really not that long
yeah
not 100-year trends in malaria but maybe
10 or 20-year trends and then improving
the assessment of the impact of
interventions and this is by removing
climate as a confounder i want to come
back to this one in particular the last
one because it may be not something
you've thought about
in too much detail
so
when we're thinking about taking science
and moving it into policy one of the
things that obviously you can tell from
my accent that i'm english and in
england we have a
national health system and as part of
that process which is very important in
the 1980s evidence-based public health
policy is an absolute mantra of the
culture of public health services and
that has spread everywhere now you see
evidence-based this evidence based that
we have to know what the value of
whatever intervention is for a
particular public health outcome and of
course there's lots of disputes about
that and so there's a process if you
like of thinking about
how to get evidence into policy and
practice and i love this um uh
little article by um sarah nutley and uh
davis and it's um basically comes up
with some lessons which i found
incredibly useful in terms of orienting
my own thinking and the first is get
agreement as to the nature of evidence
if you don't get the agreement on the
nature of evidence people just argue no
policy decisions are made and nothing
happens in terms of delivery
take a strategic approach to the
creation of evidence together with the
development of a cumulative knowledge
base it's no point having one study
saying one thing and another study
saying another thing you really have to
build a story line if you're going to
impact on policy makers
have effective dissemination of
knowledge together with the development
of a means of access to knowledge and
that's changing dramatically now of
course with the uh internet etc
and
create initiatives to increase the
uptake of evidence by both policy and
practice and so what i'm going to
present on you is some of the work that
we've been doing in this context
first of all the mechanisms issue very
very important understanding disease
mechanisms i would like to just
make the comment is we have to
understand the mechanisms and what the
drivers are as they actually work in the
field not just the lab because you'll
see that there are other things that
come into play in field environments
that you might not be so aware of in the
in the laboratory but understanding
mechanism is extremely important part of
all vector-borne diseases and very
important for policy because if you say
climate is having this impact to a
policy maker one of the first questions
is how and if they don't believe the
answer then they don't really believe
the process
we have global maps of malaria very
important the map project we've seen
their slides from earlier on putting
together these global maps of
transmission but what's actually
happening at the national level uh this
is ethiopia where i've been working for
a number of years and they have numerous
maps of malaria transmission across the
country
most of them are created from
environmental information rainfall and
temperature
maybe ndvi is included and our altitude
and those environmental maps are
produced by researchers by a large in
the north and they all look good maps
look good basically but it doesn't
necessarily mean they're used doesn't
necessarily mean they are good and it
doesn't necessarily mean they will be
used this map here was produced in the
1950s by the ethiopian ministry of
health and this is the map they use
today they have access to these other
maps why do they use their old map they
believe their old map because they
produced it it basically builds on their
expert knowledge and to bring in another
map from somewhere else they have to own
it they have to say this is our map
somehow so we can't just say by
producing new information people are
going to use that information this is
one of the tools we've developed for the
president's malaria initiative it's a
very simple tool it uses types of models
that we've seen already a basic
transmission model and
its simplicity is in the fact that you
just basically look at for any point in
africa the history of rainfall over the
last 30 years uh the history of
temperature and the history of humidity
using the crew
interpolated climate databases as the
backdrop as the information base and
what it does is it it provides the
information as a probability
distribution so you've got 30 years and
for every month it says of those 30
years
um
10 12 15 or whatever had sufficient
rainfall or sufficient temperature to
roughly
indicate the malaria transmission is
possible in this type of environment and
we combine that information produce this
probability distribution and then it's
useful to uh the president's malaria
initiative for their logistics supply
not because it provides them with
perfect information but it tells them
the likelihood i.e in these months it's
maybe only 10 out of 30 years they'll
get malaria transmission it's a
probability distribution and that's more
important than absolute information
because if you give absolute information
about uh what's going on you're
inevitably wrong if you give
probabilistic information you'll always
have the advantage of saying well just
how unlucky but it also in it also
encourages decision makers to understand
the risk of
uh taking a decision in uncertain
information so this one here is just a
little uh example from moshe and
tanzania there's a transmission from the
rainfall this is what you would actually
see if you clicked on the place and this
is what you would get for one particular
year if you looked at clinical data from
one of the hospitals
so seasonality very very important for
control very important for the timing of
interventions here's an example from
eritrea with the malaria control team
and this was how they were organizing
malaria control by region the different
colors of different regions those
regions encompass highland areas lowland
areas desert areas very complicated uh
environment and what we did with them
was to work with them to
use the health facility
data which researchers by and large
don't like because it's very poor
quality but it's no not such poor
quality that it doesn't capture the
seasonality of disease or the general
intensity of disease and so we could
re-map the country according to
areas with high transmission yellow and
red similar season areas with low
transmission the green and a similar
season and areas of orange transmission
here an intermediate area where the
season is completely different and as a
consequence they were able to reorganize
their control planning around
malaria itself and not just their
administrative boundaries
if we look at the earlier development of
early warning systems and this is what
really got me involved in this is the 98
epidemic in
northeastern kenya in wajeer and as you
can see it's a very dry environment uh
in northeastern kenya it's really goat
herding and well-heavy environment
normally they have virtually no malaria
it's a very um
the evidence for malaria here is that
it's really imported cases rainfall is
normally very low with a 97
el nino
which actually had resulted in huge
amounts of rainfall in northeastern
kenya massive local malaria epidemic and
you can see just seeing these very um
semi-arid environments they really
respond malaria really responds to
rainfall and one of the things is to
think about whether we can do something
about it this is one sad event is the
rwandan refugees moving into tanzania
with the genocide and highly predictable
malaria epidemic coming down the road
because you had a non-immune population
moving into an endemic area in tanzania
did they predict the epidemic did they
get malaria controlled into the camps in
time no but it's absolutely predictable
that that was going to happen another
thing that's absolutely predictable is
that climate change adaptation will
increase malaria in some areas and
that's because one of the major
strategies is to improve water
management uh in dry areas and to get
more surface water for gardening and
growing crops etc etc and there's plenty
of evidence that
this type of water management increases
malaria
so
early warning systems for malaria are
not new they've been used in india
over the last century particularly in
punjab and there's a long extensive
literature and interesting literature on
this and particularly the epidemics were
associated with famines and this is
something that's not just the rainfall
it's not just the mosquito it's the
vulnerability of the populations and the
epidemics in india disappeared uh really
when they actually organized famine
relief and particularly with the end of
colonialization where the food
extraction which was going on under the
british was stopped and so india's
epidemics really
they hadn't used to have huge epidemics
of malaria which was very much
associated with their famine belt
and in africa following the re-emergence
and rollback malaria in particular they
had forced um global
um pillars if you liked the global
malaria strategy one of them was control
of epidemic malaria
this was what um
working with who and the epidemic
technical team was this
model used or developed if you like to
start dealing with malaria epidemics
first on the list was understand the
vulnerability of the population which
changes over time
second incorporate anything uh that we
could on the predictability of the
climate and this was done very much when
we really didn't know that the seasonal
forecast would be that useful but we
thought it looked like a good idea
and
and then actually just monitor the
rainfall monitor the environment monitor
uh the surface water etc and finally
monitor of course what's happening in
health facilities with patients and of
course this is actually what really goes
on you wait and you have a warning of an
epidemic because you have lots of sick
people actually at the health facility
the idea of the early morning system is
to actually build some heads up
information uh that will help in the
development of the response and some of
you will have seen this before but this
is what we did in botswana where you
have extremely good malaria data and
it's right on the edge of the malaria
transmission zone it responds incredibly
well to rainfall this was what was going
on in the
malaria between 1982 and 1986 a general
upward increase in malaria uh across the
country with these
sort of occasional major epidemics and
then a policy change that was associated
with rollback malaria and the first
epidemics meeting was actually in
gaberon in 1996 and immediately you can
see the following years malaria
epidemics going down so what we're able
to do actually is to remove those trends
and just look at the
variability around the trends and see
how their connection is to climate and
what you have is the gray bars are the
um
variability in the tre from the trends
in malaria that's the anomalies the
black line is rainfall it's a quadratic
relationship which i'm not going to show
you but it's actually very linear at the
lower uh levels of malaria transmission
it's only when you get really high
transmission and it sort of curves
around the dotted line um is sea surface
temperatures here in the el nino region
and you can see sea surface temperatures
predict the rainfall in botswana
botswana rainfall predicts malaria and
there's a lot of work that was done
to try and use that information and
actually build an early warning system
using seasonal climate forecast which
could take into account those seasonal
uh those sea surface temperatures and
the results here we have the same data
again on malaria the five high malaria
years around the trend the five low
malaria years around the trend and for
the high malaria years if you look at
satellite data you realize those five
years are very wet if you look at the
seasonal forecasts which actually come
in before the rainy season those
forecasts were also for wet or actually
four out of the five years were for wet
if you look at the dry years
the satellite data indicates five years
of
drought and also the seasonal forecasts
five out of five years also indicated
drought so that gave us some
confidence that seasonal forecasting may
be used in malaria early warning systems
and incorporated into planning cycles
and what have you for malaria control
the work was done in collaboration with
who and the southern african malaria
control unit and the different countries
one of the challenges from a policy
perspective is that seasonal forecasting
is not uniform over the continent and
countries do not like products where
they can where you say yes this will
work in the north but not in the south
or it'll work in march and april but not
in june and july or on a wednesday or
whatever that's not good for policy and
so there's a challenge fundamental
challenge on the seasonal forecasting
side because it's
in theory very useful and in specific
areas highly predictable but it's not
simple to incorporate it in a policy
environment but we are seeing that
increasingly done so
in different countries here's some work
that you may have seen we had already
mentioned caricho in the east african
highlands um
well there's been a lot of work on a lot
of discussion about the longer term
trends and this was the original data
from simon hayetal and here's the
picture of the tier states etc
and
with all of the discussion on uh warming
in the east african highlands first of
all you need to think about what are the
questions we're trying to answer the
first was has malaria increased in the
east african highlands and the answer to
that was a react resounding yes um i was
at the first epidemics meeting it was in
ethiopia i think it was in 1998
and it was specifically a response to
the fact that epidemics were being
observed in kenya in uganda in ethiopia
in tanzania in these highland areas and
there's nobody's disputed that malaria
increased in the 80s and 90s and early
2000s in the highlands
has temperature increased in the east
african highlands that has proved an
awful lot harder to actually answer and
this is partly the disconnect between
climate research and actually what we
know about what's happening on the
ground and um
you can't really answer the question
c
or d if you don't know whether or not
it's been warming which is whether or
not
an increase in cases
in the east african highlands is related
to warming and whether or not warming is
related to what's happening on the
global scale
so there's a lot of lot of literature
about this in particular you'll see this
often cited paul writer in particular
but others as well
the original studies by hay they didn't
see any observed change is in the trend
and cited that well-maintained
meteorological records show no
significant change in temperature over
recent decades
so that has been a major part of the
literature that there was no change in
temperature
and
one of the challenges has been that the
data sets are used are these globally
available data sets and this is what
happens as us as global researchers
international researchers we can access
very easily the global data it's much
harder to access the local data the uea
is an excellent data set
particularly for
uh climate scientists to do large scale
climate science but it's not quite so
good at doing uh detailed local analysis
for one particular t state and the
reason for that is if you look in the
data uh one is that the sorry i'll just
go back to the slide here this is what
it looks like and this is why i talk
about this looks great grid points
everywhere nice colors etc but when you
look at the underlying data you realize
there's very few met stations that are
actually represented in the data set and
even on some years not that many this is
just from one particular month it was in
july 1988
1998 so what happens with a climate
scientist when they don't have data they
collapse it back to the mean so you tend
not to see information if
if the data is poor
and you can see that over the time
period that the data set is available or
the early data set was available from
the 19
early 1900s to
2000 and so
there's a big variation in the number of
stations for which temperature was
available or rainfall was available or
humidity was available and in fact there
were no there was no station informative
information for vapor pressure at all
even though vapor pressure was described
in writer's paper as detailed records on
vapor pressure et cetera so actually
understanding what's in the maps and in
the data sets is incredibly important as
part of the collaborative effort between
climate scientists and health scientists
this was the first analysis by climate
scientists that i have seen on east
africa and it came out in 2009 sort of a
long time after the big all these
discussions on uh temperature and it
basically indicates warming um at least
a minimum temperature not of maximum
temperature
across kenya
we worked with the
kenyan
national meteorological agency and
my colleagues climate colleagues at the
iri julia mungo led this paper and
coming from kenya herself that was
incredibly important because it allowed
her to engage directly with the national
met services give them confidence about
the exchange of data and what we would
do with the data
the data was accessed for creature
itself so this is the actual station
data for carricho and you can see there
are big problems uh with the data sets
in its raw form because you get these
jumps
these jumps are associated sometimes
with them moving the
net station uh there's standardized
protocols within wmo and our climate
scientists and the met scientists that
all uh worked on the data to produce
quality controlled time series and
that's the data that we've been able to
use in the analysis so this analysis
then has as a backdrop there's no actual
climate
malaria analysis in this as the backdrop
you have the malaria data from the
creature
tear states
but the green line that you see is the
actual minimum temperature from that
particular station
and that green line is highly correlated
i think you can see it visually with not
only uh the tropical land surface
temperature so that's the land surface
the temperature around the equator but
also the sea surface temperature
around the equator as well and you can
also see the impact of el nino and la
nina effects and this is the big 98 uh
el 9798 el nino you can see the impact
on minimum temperature you can see the
impact on malaria and you can see the
impact in all of the global data sets on
temperature
so
you can start to connect what's
happening locally i was amazed when i
saw these results that you could
actually see such a connection between
one single station and what was going on
uh globally um
daniel ruiz uh my uh
phd student who is doing the mechanistic
model he hopefully will
be presenting his results uh in the near
future and he's by using a
dynamical model or a mathematical model
you can start connecting both
temperature and rainfall because if you
only look at one
you'll actually
you may over interpret what you're
seeing
so
is it important creatures at about 2000
meters so and the ethiopians used 2000
meters as their cutoff point for
epidemics 2000 meters 800 1800 meters or
whatever there's people use altitude as
a proxy for temperature as a convenient
proxy
um and there has been uh some discussion
does it matter
it matters in some places quite a lot
half of the ethiopian population live
above 2000 meters so they live in a
potentially epidemic zone or a zone
where you could have a big imp increase
from um
uh
warming and in potential increase from
malaria in the region
very important to note actually what's
happening with malaria though malaria
hasn't been increasing since about 2004
in korecho this is the big declines in
malaria that have been going on
and um
this is an important part of the control
strategies and they that have moved into
you know increase in bed nets changes in
drugs uh spray routines etc there's a
huge a huge effort to get in malaria
control and hopefully this is evidence
of the impact of that
control but
it might not be the only thing that is
affecting it and
one of the things that's been going on
in
east africa and is really important in
terms of trying to translate some of the
climate
science work particularly the long-term
climate change with actually policy
because malaria control policy when they
started with a 1990 uh 1998 rollback
malaria they had a 30-year time frame
for malaria control in africa and
globally but fundamentally in africa uh
so that's a long time frame for uh a
decision maker in uh
public health decision maker but the
day-to-day changes in policy as you've
seen they change fairly rapidly over
five
15 year time periods
they have a much shorter thinking in
terms of what you're actually going to
do on a day-to-day basis and
so this is a climate change
ipcc prediction that it's going to get
wetter in east africa which may well be
true but when is it going to get wetter
because this is actually what's been
happening this is chris funk's analysis
of the drought in eastern africa and
this most importantly is
work by
brad lyon and dave dewitt on
what's been going on in east africa in
terms of the temporal
patterns of the drought
and so you've had 10 years of drought i
think the discussion between these two
uh scientists as far as i understand it
is that chris funk thinks this is this
drought is part of a long-term slow
decline uh related to climate change in
some way and the to uh brad lyon and
dave dewitt's view is that actually no
this is a climate shift that happened
really in 1990 there was a fairly
constant climate until then and then
there's been a drop in rainfall in the
region which itself should have big
impact on malaria about a 15 drop in
malaria there was a 30 to 40 percent
drop in rainfall in the sahel during the
major parts of the sahelian drought and
as a result we saw loss of vector
species major declines in malaria
changes in vector populations etc does a
15 rain
drop in rainfall is that going to have
an impact on malaria
undoubtedly yes
but
how much how important relative to all
those control issues um
it's not clear so if i ever i'm in a
situation where i have to talk to policy
makers about climate change
and i only have one slide this is the
one i show them because it's such a
challenge for people to understand
long-term change year-to-year
variability and then in particular the
way that uh decadal verified
confounds
uh short-term policy well even
longest-term policy-making because if
for malaria control they want a policy
that's going to be for the next 10 years
do they look at longer-term change
models do they look at seasonal
forecasting or do they basically
understand that decadal processes may
affect
rainfall
much more than any of the longer term
changes in their decision time frame and
that at the moment is not really
predictable as far unless somebody here
can tell me that it is so that is a big
challenge for control
and control thinking
so uh from a policy perspective we need
to think about
multiple time frames and at the end of
the day we have to focus on the time
frame for which decision
what types of decisions are relevant
for particular disease control
issues and mostly they're relevant
within a four-year time frame if you're
lucky a 10-year time frame and if it's
unusual like malaria you might be
thinking out 20 years 30 years that will
be really a thing around things like
vaccine development etc
so
um
the last one on my list is uh
thinking about climate as a confounder
and this is really important now that we
have those billion dollars going into
malaria control before uh the
um you know the previous uh decades
where
in the 1990s 1980s there was very little
money going into malaria research there
was very little money going into malaria
control
i
estimated there was one vector control
state in florida you had much more
resources for vector control than the
whole of africa
and that was the reality i mean the
so the whole issue about monitoring and
surveillance and what have you was very
poorly developed but now that there are
big resources going in and people say
well you know where are those resources
going
you know the malaria control people have
to answer to congress we gave you a
billion dollars how many kids lives has
it saved that's really the bottom line
and so it's very difficult to monitor
changes in malaria when you don't know
what the baseline malaria is to start
with really you have a vague idea and b
you don't know what the current malaria
situation is really you just have a
vague idea and you have many many
confounding factors so you can have the
drought is the drought responsible for
the decline in malaria maybe it's not
the billion dollar intervention is um a
girl's education is it the vitamin a
supplementation is it all sorts of other
things so the poor people in the
monitoring evaluation reference group
who have to develop strategies for
trying to give a best estimation of
the effectiveness of the
of the resources that are now going into
malaria control have to take into
account confounders and as a minimalist
these confounders include
contextual factors such as the
epidemiology of malaria and issues like
climate
so how they're going to do that how are
they going to do that in a continent
where
has only less than an eighth of the of
the meteorological stations that are
considered basic
for running an observation system uh by
wmn
it's a big challenge what's the way that
it can confound this is a study we did
in eritrea uh there was the world bank
was investing heavily in malaria control
along with usaid and they published uh
this article
uh how the malaria burden was
successfully reduced in brazil eritrea
india and vietnam based largely on this
data which was the incidence data
for the country
from 1998 6 through to 2003 and eritrea
is very proud of the fact it was one of
the first countries to achieve
initial goals
and it has
rightly uh you know an effective malaria
control program um however uh one of the
things that we pointed out was just to
look at the ndvi for eritrea at the same
time and as you can see the ndvi and the
malaria incidents actually match pretty
well
and
basically what happened here they used
as their baseline year 1999 because they
always like to use a baseline and
after 1999 every other year was much
drier
so if you have a baseline in a wet year
and you're monitoring in dry years
you're pretty guaranteed success
we did a much more detailed study uh
with patricia graves who did
and was able to tease out the rainfall
contribution to the decline and the
intervention contribution to the decline
and it sort of came out about half and
half so they were definitely doing
something good
but they were being helped on the way by
the drought
and so this is the formula that we've
been developing with the president's
malaria initiative like how they should
think about climate information in terms
of
interventions and that we need some
estimate of
um
is the climate suitability for malaria
transmission increasing following the
intervention staying roughly the same or
decreasing and to get some vague idea
about that because if they don't
incorporate an increase in climate
suitability they might underestimate the
benefits of what they've been doing
and if they
don't take account like an eritrea that
malaria transmission uh suitability has
decreased then they may overestimate the
benefits of their intervention now you
may say that's fine from a policy people
like it malaria control managers love
droughts everything works they can go to
the minister they say malaria is gone
down but you have the problem in three
years later the rain come back the rains
come back and
it looks like you haven't done a good
job so what we're trying to do is get
them to use climate information
routinely to improve their analysis so a
they're not surprised either way they
account better they can go to congress
and nobody can say well what it was
driven by the drought they can say no
we've checked that out and
we know that the drought only
contributed x amount to the declining
cases
so there are big policy gaps in um
uh
going between thinking about doing
something with climate and malaria in
africa and doing something and these
gaps
at multiple levels this was a report
that we did for
the department for international
development and i'm not going to talk
about it because i'm talking too long
but basically there are gaps on the
policy
services practice and data side and we
need to get these communities to work
much more effectively together i'm going
to skip that and just go to this which
is what we're now doing to try and
improve climate information availability
and use in africa our first uh work is
in ethiopia it's led here at our
meteorologist tufa dinkum and it's to
create
high quality
data sets at the national level owned by
uh the government uh delivered through
the national meteorological agency at
much higher resolution much better
quality than anything you can get at the
global scale and then to turn that
information into products and services
that can be used for development this is
the data here the national
meteorological stations for ethiopia
very good
station
set actually for any country in africa
if you look at a global product it
probably incorporates about 14 met
stations for rainfall if at the country
level is about 600.
here's satellite data pretty crude gives
you a nice overall picture you combine
the two together you get the high
quality of the observations plus the
spatial structure of the satellite data
and that's we've done the same thing for
temperature and now you have high
resolution products which go back 30
years because it uses 30 years of
meteosat data
and it can be a 10 daily resolution and
you can query it and make i showed you
this product previously
that we used for pmi but now you can
click on it with much higher resolution
data and look at a specific localities
you can also look at the trends in
temperature this is unprecedented now
instead of waiting uh 10 years to find
out what was happening in one tier state
we can now see and click at any
resolution that we want to across the
country uh what's been happening on the
temperature what's the history of
rainfall anomalies and we can use these
to create products such as the weighted
um average
i'm sorry my voice is running out so
about basically this says here in
ethiopia this is the intervention period
uh 2000 no this is the baseline period
that they used 2000 to 2005. this is the
intervention period the intervention
period was wetter than the baseline they
don't have to worry about drought being
an important part in oromia
and you can look at this at multiple
spatial scales and the same thing in
tanzania you can see the changes in
temperature and the history of rainfall
and you can get this this is important
in tanzania in tanzania what you have
they use a baseline 95 to 2000 for their
malaria interventions that happens to
include the el nino event with a huge
amount of malaria and the subsequent
intervention period has these three
major droughts in it and
in the literature you'll see for
tanzania they identified declines in
malaria before the interventions they
identified changes from gamly to
arabiensis before the interventions so
there's a problem about separating out
what the impact of drought is in
tanzania in terms of the control issues
and the key thing then of course is uh
having a population uh that can use the
information understand the information
locally to make products and services uh
that can affect their own decision
making and we do a lot on training so
with all of the work that is possible on
climate the most interesting thing and
the one that's had the biggest traction
so far with the health community is
improving their own evaluations
and the reason why i think this is
particularly important is it will get us
i think you'll see over the next two
years but every malaria control program
in africa looking at climate
just because they'll feel it's part of
good practice uh in terms of their
accountability issues and with that
information they'll also learn about
their trends their year-to-year
variability their seasonality etc
without having to
approach it in that way and so there's a
big change now in the african context in
terms of engaging the policy side the
practice side the creation of climate
services and
data and uh right thank you very much
you